[Musique]
et financièrement et pour en parler un
spécialiste un journaliste de paris
match est avec nous c'est benjamin
locoge merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
désactivons première question c'est quoi
pour elle le véritable enjeu de son
retour en france c'est quoi c'est
l'image ou l'argent l'enjeu de ce retour
en france est de présenter ce disque que
johnny a conçu comme son dernier album
son album posthume
elles étaient en studio avec lui l
accompagner jusqu à là jusqu'à la mort
et elle veut que cette affaire ça et
jusqu'au bout donc elle était sa
directrice artistique
elle vient expliquer pourquoi johnny
fait cet album on parle est ce que c'est
vrai ou pas d'une avance qu'aurait fait
warner pour que les gens comprennent
comment ça marche quand on va sortir on
donne une avance d'argent icwa senteurs
et puis ensuite selon les ventes' à plus
de vent des touches plus long feu
rappeler juste que johnny a toujours été
interprète il n'y avait pas auteur
compositeur donc les ventes de disques
vont le produit des ventes de 10 va
principalement aux auteurs et aux vieux
comme on s'attend à un gros carton il y
aurait une avance à 20 millions d'euros
une semaine avant sa mort johnny a signé
un contrat comme quoi il avait terminé
ce disque est donc il a touché une
avance de warner sa maison dix comme il
le faisait à chaque album il l'a fait
chez universal il a fait chez warner
c'était sa manière de vivre et la gueule
toujours sur des avances donc laetitia a
profité de cette avance qui a été versé
en novembre 2010 êtes vous quand
certains disent que grosso modo la peur
de la parole pendant un an avec elle la
retrouve au moment de la promotion du
disque qu'est ce que vous dites c'est ce
qui était prévu
elle avait elle a parlé au père est déjà
bien ça comme agir comme elle le peut
elle s'attendait pas à se prendre
effectivement ses tombereaux de merde
comme johnny il avait prévu dans la dans
la figure au moins deux mois de février
elle a pris ça d'une manière assez comme
ça
elle fait comme elle peut aller par mes
ailes et voilà il n'ya pas dix mille
conseillers autour d'elle contrairement
à ce qu'on croit et à sébastien farran
le son le manager historique il ya
mathieu laine qui est toujours là et
c'est tout avant donner la parole à lui
qu'est ce qu'on sait à peu près déjà
quel est le montant aujourd'hui on a
tout entendu par des 30 millions 10
millions
est ce qu'on sait à peu près le montant
du patrimoine qu'il va falloir partager
ou non avec les enfants avec l'été avec
laura et aujourd'hui alors on parle non
puisque la justice n'a pas fini son
travail
donc nous on ne sait pas quelle est la
fortune réelle de johnny hallyday mais y
en a beaucoup moins que ce qu'on imagine
surtout ça c'est aussi pour ça qu'elle
est obligée de se battre à prix réel
mais deux moto et une voiture dans un
trust deux motos une voiture c'est pas
des actions séparées
rien de très compliqué de faire le
montant parce que mon tout étant sa
retraite dont tout le monde parle en âge
qu'on ne les aime pas beaucoup de jeu
notamment peut-être j'aimerais avoir le
lui parce que là ce qui n'ôte et associe
c'est le voyage elle débarque en france
n a pas mis les pieds en france il
paraît qu'elle a très peur qu'elle a
pris des gardes du corps et avec des
détails justement sur le le séjour en
france de laëtitia elle va arriver le 5
octobre avec sa mère françoise avec mamy
rock ce qu'on a bien vert pendant les
avec aussi sa belle-soeur que l'ancienne
nourrice des petits ont elles devraient
toutes les trois là bas dans la maison
dans la conquête c'est là qu'elles vont
rester
elle va pas rester très longtemps en
france parce que oui elle a peur et
c'est pas quelque chose qui lui fit
d'abord il faudrait qu'elle se confronte
aux médias aussi qu'ils vont peut-être
poser des questions qui la dérange
et puisqu'elle se confronte à un peu
l'opinion bien dans les rues etc
los angeles elle est les personnes et
c'est mieux pour elle quoi d'accord elle
va rester du 5 octobre le voir partir le
23 octobre direct pour saint-barth cette
fois pour faire encore un hommage à
johnny ou non de toussaint faire une
fête et après elle repart direct à los
angeles elle peut plus revenir né à
saint barth et en france parce que sinon
elle perd son statut de résident aux
états unis parce qu'elle n'a pas à ses
186 jours de résidence aux usa ni quand
même donc il faut que non parce qu'il
faut que la moitié de l'année à los
angeles pour rester résidente
bien sûr il a les a pas entre la maladie
johnny entre les stations d'hiver pardon
je disais que
il ya beaucoup d'argent il ya pas de
temps d'argent contre pense là quand
même de l'argent ya plus que le commun
des mortels il paraît chez simyo lignac
a un peu d'argent et un trust pour les
pour les revenus les revenus de ses
ventes de disques à un trust pour les
souliers sur le patrimoine il ya un trou
dont il ya du quart d'entre eux mêmes
l'avocat était tellement sûr qu'il y
aurait une plainte des enfants contre le
testament qui donc fini par déserter les
enfants il ya eu aussi des stars il faut
le rappeler d'avocats était tellement
sûr de ça je pense qu'il ya un jeu
passif est sûre en tout cas et même un
trust qui prévoyait frais d'avocat donc
c'est pour vous dire que voilà il ya
quand même quand on connaît pas du tout
c'est que dans cette histoire
l'impression que c'est une presqu'île vu
la haine des gens contre elle alors
après moi j'ai eu quelques personnes à
la production je veux dire trop qui mais
ils disent que dans les fagnes à il ya
un tiers contre et deux tiers
quand même pour elle mais on a
l'impression que c'est marc chotteau
d'amérique est-ce que vous pensez que
les fans ne vont pas jeter de rabat non
puisque ce métier juste pardon sébastien
est ce que oui ou non du coup j'imagine
que tous les paparazzis de france nîmes
n'a pas retenu 5 octobre heure de
l'avion vous avez tous est dessus et
comme vous voulez tous est dessus qu'est
ce que vous cherchez de différents
voulait la photo la photo meilleur quoi
elle en fait je pense non qu'ils veulent
je pense que ça va être très verrouillé
en +100 dira on dit qu'un cortège pardon
je coupe indiqué un cortège de biker qui
va l'accompagner de l'avion jusqu'à chez
elle à mindin coquette parce qu'elle n'a
pas envie d'y aller d'accord ce cas là
les jetons sa pensée dire autour depuis
la mort de johnny et j'ai aussi une
question parce que c'est la question que
pose aussi en début d'émission donc
vraiment ce notamment pour pour myriam
et pour lui qu est ce que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment quand même d'avoir pris
partie on le voit encore ici qu'on fait
la une avec c'est la nôtre peut-être
avec sébastien on nous accuse justement
d'être trop gentil la défendre de la
défense alors que n'ont fait que
raconter les faits et non c'est vrai que
c'est pas toi pas cette semaine pourrait
la maladrerie
on est bien on a convenu que johnny
était parfaitement sain d'esprit et de
corps quand il a fait ses stamm ans donc
le premier responsable c'est lui
m